what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or brawl and today i will be
breaking down and explaining every
esparta's power from bleach the espada
are all insanely powerful a wrong car
and are without a doubt some of bleach's
best designs when it comes to its
characters
now if you do enjoy these bleach videos
on the channel and you'd like to see
more you know what to do a smash that
like button get sugar 10 show style if
you haven't already make this the video
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications
you can also follow us on twitter and
instagram at anime uproar
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all
the espada are made up of ten
exceptional aranka that boast insane
strength and spiritual power they are
ranked zero through to nine and the
lower the number the stronger that
asparta is
each of these as spada have their rank
tattooed somewhere on their body now
espada is the spanish word for sword and
the japanese for 10 blades the espada
alongside tozen kaname gene ichimaru and
of course sosuke eisen himself are all
on par with the goti 13 when it comes to
their power
the sparta themselves are eisen's most
direct subordinates though the asparta
did already exist prior to eisen's
betrayal of the soul society once eisen
arrived the espada became one of his
most important structures and the
members as well as their positions were
changed eisen had such a respect for his
espada well more so for their abilities
than anything else and was also very
lenient with them as long as they
remained loyal and carried out his plans
but he would also trust them with his
intimate plans such as the destruction
of karakuro town as an obvious example
the creation of the oaken as well as the
hokioku's location within los noches was
also trusted to them if only to test a
select few
as such eisen would discuss his plans
and the events of waco mundo with his
dearest spada directly sitting on the
same table with them he trusted his
espada with important and very dangerous
missions such as gathering information
from the human world fighting those
within the goatee 13 themselves and so
on
now becoming an espada was the goal for
any iran car as you possessed great
power held rank over others were in
direct contact with eisen and had a host
of other luxuries which included having
your own quarters within los noches that
were designed to suit that espada's very
specific needs
being his most direct subordinates and a
sparta has an insane amount of power as
well as leadership capabilities with
each of them able to execute command
over eisen's forces within his
stronghold of lost notice his forces
included numerous who were combat
experts amongst the iranka
as well as that he had the exaquious who
were the execution division
each of the espada also had their own
fraxion or subordinate officers that the
espada had chosen specifically from the
numerators when it comes to power the
difference between a spada and his
fraxion was likened to that of a captain
in the gotai 13 and their lieutenants
however the espada was much
much stronger than those in his or her
fraxion
the command also reaches to the espadas
rank the higher ranking espada would
still dish out orders to the lower
ranked spartas and they would follow the
higher ranks command well supposedly
anyway there was a lot of infighting
amongst the ranks of the espada just as
you see in any group such as these
now the lower ranks would often take the
lead and use their own initiative
however the higher ranks were a lot more
like trained loyal dogs in the fact that
they would follow eisen's every command
to the very word
and despite their infighting the espada
were very loyal to one another the
higher ranks would be the first to try
and bail out the lower ranks for their
mistakes and they had a mutual bond that
above all they wished to prevent losing
one of their own
now when it came to power each of the
espada boasts incredible spiritual power
and are masters in combat they were keen
strategists expert swordsmen and masters
of high speed movement as a spada they
all had their own unique set of powers
and abilities but they also shared some
espada exclusive abilities such as carja
negasion which was a variant of the
gillian exclusive ability negacion which
was a beam used by hollows to rescue
their comrades carja negasion was a
cube-shaped device that would simulate
the same effects as the negation fields
the cube would trap their target in an
ultimate dimension that an average a
wrong car could not escape this was
often used by an espada as a form of
punishment to those in their fraxion and
though it could be used on other espada
it rarely was this was due to the fact
that their power was of course far
greater than that of an average iran car
and they would be able to escape that
alternate dimension in only a matter of
time
gran rey cerro is a variation of the
seto technique where the espada can mix
their own blood with the blast of the
shadow to greatly enhance this attack
power its power is great in so much that
it would disturb the very fabric of
space
and they can also use an ability called
sedo ascoras which was again another
variant of the seto used in their
released state
as well as this the espada had their own
zompoc toe each with their own sets of
unique powers and abilities then of
course there was their resurrection this
is where they released that weapon seal
unleashing their true power and true
forms to return to their humanoid form
they simply reseal their power within
its sort form the espada who were ranked
fourth or higher i.e between four and
zero were all actually forbidden from
using their zampac toe within lost note
chests and all espada were forbidden
from using a gran rey seto due to both
insane destructive power either of these
are said to be enough to completely
destroy the majority of lost no chess
so with that rundown on the espada let's
look into the powers and abilities of
the espada starting from the lowest rank
of 9 through to the top dog at zero
adeniero was the ninth ranked of eisens
espada his tattoo location is on his top
and bottom heads each of the espada all
represent an aspect of death and
arenaro's is greed as well as having all
the traits we had mentioned previously
in regards to him being a master
swordsman a keen strategist a sonito
expert as an espotter etc arena had an
ability called cognition synchronization
where he could instantly broadcast any
and all information that he was either
seeing or experiencing to his comrades
his zampocto was called glottaneria
which is spanish for the word gluttony
and japanese for hollow eater the form
of his zompoc toe was that of a real
nasty looking brown tentacle attached to
his arm that had a gaping worm-like
mouth with many other tentacles this was
oftenly hid under a glove on his left
hand its abilities included hollow
absorption now hollows were cannibals in
the fact that they would pray and feed
on one another in order to gain more
power in the hope of rising through the
ranks when they got smart enough
adenyero's ability was unique in the
fact that he could absorb dead hollows
and still gain both its spirit power and
abilities
this allowed him to evolve without limit
unlike normal hollows and as such was
the only gillian class menos amongst the
espada adeniero claimed to have eaten
and gained the strength of around 33
650 hollows by the time he fought with
rukia kuchki
another scary ability of glottaneria is
its aspect manifestation in which it
allowed adenyero to perfectly copy and
manifest any of those that he had
previously absorbed this included that
person's knowledge and memories physical
form and powers even their muscle memory
was replicated so that his battle style
became an exact copy of the originals
not only that but adeniello could also
call upon and use any of the powers he
absorbed from others whenever he so
chose
adenyero absorbed metastasia who was an
experimental hollow used by eisen and
thus showcased some of the powers he
gained from him which included the
ability to merge his own body with other
beings including shinigami he could also
destroy a shinigami zampak toe if they
were to simply touch one of his
tentacles when he was in his released
form now let's talk about arenero's
research it was activated by using the
command devour
when released it turned his lower body
into a huge purple like blob which
looked kind of like an octopus it had
dozens of again
tentacles as well as large red eyes and
a huge mouth with nasty looking teeth
at the center of this was a bubbling
area that would display the masks of
random hollows that aren'iero had
consumed
in his resurrection state adenyero
stated he could manifest the power of
all of those 33
650 hollows that he had consumed at once
making him a one-man army when it came
to his power
was the eighth ranked of eisens espada
his tattoo location is unknown but his
aspect of death was madness
now he is the top researcher and
spiritual weapons specialist of the
espada unlike mayuri from the soul
society he's certainly a bit twisted
when it comes to the experiments and
such
zaya laporo had a very unique fraxion
that he had modded before having them
turned into a wrong car he wasn't just
smart scientifically but was also a
master of invention as he had created a
maze that would constantly shift
throughout his domain in waco mundo and
within this ever-changing maze were
traps laying in weight to ensnare his
prey
he again like mayuri loved to thoroughly
analyze his opponent's abilities so that
he could completely nullify them on the
battlefield the only problem when facing
zai lapotto is that his analyzing was
all done there and then on the
battlefield the speed at which he could
completely break down and attacks
components and then rendered them
completely useless in such a short time
was amazing but also very
very scary his zompakto was called
fornicatus which meant consort of
lewdness in japanese pretty strange
right anyway his zombocto had the
appearance of a regular katana zaya
laparos rezalexion release is sip he
actually releases it by calling out his
command and then completely swallowing
the sword he undergoes a change in which
the lower half of his body becomes
tentacle-like with his feet appearing
beneath them his attire is like a
layered dress with white sleeves
extending from his elbow in these white
sleeves were more tensile like things
hanging from them his hollow mask takes
the form of a headdress that is a thin
band around his forehead and extends
under his eyes to look like glasses as
well as this he also gains wings that
again have those same tentacle drippings
coming off of them
in this form the wings act as a form of
defense where he will wrap them around
himself thickening till he takes the
form of a ball that will block any
oncoming attacks zaya laporo's release
state gives him quite a few different
and definitely unique and powerful
abilities
he has carbon copy where a black liquid
will come out of his back that will make
an exact copy of his opponent that will
be able to use the same abilities of the
one that it had copied even if it was
simply a single drop of this liquid that
touches his opponent its effects remain
the same and it must be mentioned that
he can also modify these clones to his
liking this in zaya lapotto's case is
often aesthetic changes to suit his own
standards let's say
he has an ability called puppet theater
where he can grab an opponent with one
of his wings and then spit them out one
of the strands of his wings fills up
with a purple liquid that bursts open
revealing a voodoo-like doll of his
victim
any damage done to the doll and in
particular its organs will be dealt
directly to the one to whom the doll is
linked to zayal apollo loves to toy with
his victims by using this technique he
will take the doll apart and take the
organs out one by one being a very
knowledgeable man he knows exactly which
organs to destroy that will keep his
victim alive while inflicting
devastating pain to them
zayal apollo can also liquefy his own
body so that if he is eaten he can
invade that person's nervous system and
completely take control of that body
the final ability we know of is called
gabriel which is japanese for notice of
conception this ability allows him to be
reborn if he was fatally injured by get
this
impregnating his enemy
yeah
so when he makes physical contact with
another he can implant a portion of
himself within their body to which he
will then eat his way out of them while
absorbing all of their fluids and
chemicals this is both a very nasty and
fatal ability to his victim
zaya laporo comes out of his victim in a
liquid form and will then develop his
body back to its original state in a
matter of seconds
zamarri is the seventh ranked of eisens
espada his tattoo location is unknown
and his aspect of death is hedoism
zamarri holds the title for the fastest
cenido not only among all of the aranka
but the espada too
he moves so fast that if he was to
increase the speed of his steps by just
a tiny amount it would begin to make
clones of himself that he refers to as
like a kind of magic trick this trick is
used to both confuse and surprise his
opponent
zamari has stated that he can make up to
five speed clones using this technique
using them for diverse and
multi-directional attacks
now zamari zompakto is called brugeria
which is spanish for the word witchcraft
and japanese for cursing eye monk its
appearance is that of a normal katana
and his resurrection's release command
is subside his body becomes covered in
50 open eyes and his legs turn into that
of a pink pumpkin he gains a skull-like
neck brace that has an open eye on the
front
the abilities of his release stay are
all based around the eyes in this new
form so zamari can take control of one
object per eye once the object is under
his control a sun-shaped mark will
appear on it and this gives zamari full
control over said object the insane
thing is that he can use this on one of
the limbs of his opponent once under his
control that person's brain can no
longer influence the use or movement of
said limb to which zamori will often
cause that person to injure themselves
with it not only that but he can also
use it to reduce that person's movement
now if he chooses to take control of a
person's head then he will gain control
over that person's entire body of course
if his gaze is interrupted then control
of that object is lost
he has another ability called the embryo
which is a defensive one where that
lower half of his body will become a
full sphere protecting the upper half of
his body too
this of course breaks the gaze of his
eyes that are controlling objects but it
is a super strong defense
it was even able to hold off biaquia's
zembon zagra kageyoshi
next up is greemjao who is the sixth
ranked of eisens asparda his tattoo
location is on the right side of his
lower back and the aspect of death that
he represents is destruction
greengel is an absolute powerhouse he is
a master of hand-to-hand combat and an
expert swordsman he has an ability
called hiero which is spanish for iron
and japanese for iron skin where he was
able to stop the attack from a released
shikai with just his bare hand receiving
absolutely no damage at all he was even
able to grab ichigo's bonkai in the same
manner as just described which is just
crazy
his zompocto is called pantera not to be
mistaken with the band this is spanish
for the word panther and japanese for
panther king he was able to perform a
partial transformation of his released
state where his hands changed to that of
black claws similar to that of course
of a panther
sticking with the transformation topic
the release command for his resurrection
is grind his appearance completely
changes matching that of his panther
theme the clause of course from his
partial transformation not only has his
hands changed but his feet too his teeth
become much more jagged and feline like
he also gains the addition of a long
whip like tail his hair grows in length
and the markings around his eyes have
become enlarged his ears also increase
in length to look more feline like the
mask around his jaw is now a headband
that covers his forehead
so in terms of power once his
resurrection has been released his
strength speed and agility are all
dramatically increased as well as his
yellow that we mentioned earlier making
him incredibly hard to damage
he also had a sonic wave ability where
he would raw at the top of his lungs
creating a sonic wave so powerful that
it would completely destroy that in the
surrounding area and knock his opponents
off guard
then there was gara de la pantera which
was spanish for claw of the panther and
japanese for panther hooks this ability
is where green jiao would fire bombs
from his elbow at incredibly fast speeds
in fact green gel could fire up to five
bombs all at once
these bombs were green in colour and
looked like crystal darts strong enough
to take out columns over 30 meters in
diameter and credit to our boy a hollow
masked ichigo somehow managed to
withstand five of these bombs and was
still able to keep fighting green gel
the last ability which green gel claimed
to be his strongest is called descaron
which is spanish for laceration or great
hair and japanese for panther king's
claw his claws begin to glow and he
makes a slashing motion aimed towards
his target and each of his claws become
a sharp and long blade made of spiritual
energy that are then hurled straight at
them green gel can swing a maximum of 10
of these blades at a target this ranged
attack is not only incredibly powerful
but also controlled making them near
impossible to dodge or block
loopy was the sixth ranked espada in
eisens command temporarily replacing
green jail before being killed by
yeah green gel himself so his tattoo
location is on his right hip and his
aspect of death is unknown
he was a pretty strong character but
nothing compared to green joe at all
loopy had all the traits and abilities
of an espada but nothing really that
individual until of course we look into
his zompoc toe and res alexion so his
zompoc toe was called trepadora which is
spanish for climbing vine and japanese
for ivy maiden his zompok toe was like
that of a kadachi lupi's resurrection
command was strangle and when activated
he gained eight huge tentacles connected
at his back in a hexagon shape now is it
just me or do a lot of these are spider
powers that we've covered so far anyway
involved tentacles is so japanese
anyway so his resurrection special
ability of course all revolve around the
eight tentacles on his back and he has
four abilities we know of that include
lanza tentaculo this is spanish for
lance tentacle and japanese for tactile
lands
as the name suggests lupi uses his
tentacle as a lance as he thrusts one of
them at very high speeds right towards
his target with a force that to be fair
to him is no joke
jawler tentaculo spanish for cage
tentacle and japanese for tactile cage
is an attack utilizing all of his eight
tentacles where he will attack his
target from multiple angles yeah just
like that of a cage where he will then
crush them with devastating force
la helis which is spanish for the
propeller and japanese for whirling arm
array is where lupi will use his
tentacles like a helicopter spinning
them at incredible speeds allowing him
to attack multiple targets at once or
hitting one target multiple times with
these high speed powerful powerful
whip-like attacks
the final ability is called hero vergen
which is both spanish and japanese for
iron maiden the tentacles coming from
his back all gain additional spikes at
their ends which will inflict additional
injury on top of his usual whip-like
attacks
nuitora is the fifth espada in eisens
ranks his tattoo location is on his
tongue and his aspect of death is
despair
he holds the title of the holder of the
strongest hero of all aranka and that's
including all espada both past and
present too this allows him to withstand
pretty much almost any attack without
receiving a single scratch of damage
his zambocto is called santa teresa
which means praying mantis and is
japanese for sacred screaming praying
mantis so noitore's zampocto is unique
compared to the others as instead of
being a standard sword type it is that
of a giant axe scythe it takes the form
of two crescent moon shaped blades
and due to its difference noitora is a
master scytheman who is trained
relentlessly with his weapon wielding it
with complete ease and translating his
savage nature into its attacks
his relaxion command is prey in his
released form noitora gains the addition
of an extra pair of arms that as well as
his previous arms look like that of an
insects each hand wields a giant scythe
weapon as well which really goes with
his praying mantis-like theme as well as
this he gains a gold marking that goes
from his forehead to below his right eye
and the addition of horns shaped again
like a crescent moon where the left horn
is longer than the right
his hollow mask also changes where it is
now torn that has teeth all extending
over his hole
now the special ability of his
resurrection is basically the addition
of his arms and scythes but he also
gains a considerable boost to his
already overwhelming physical abilities
so we're talking enhanced strength and
spiritual power here as well as that he
has very high speed regeneration where
any wounds inflicted are all healed
within an instant can i say that's
already on top of his extreme hero
yeah
he can also grow an extra set of arms
below the others giving him a total of
six all of course with scythe he tends
to keep the third pair hidden and will
use them as a sort of surprise attack
and noitora also has weapon generation
where he can grow his scythe-like
weapons from his wrist if he needed to
replace lost or damaged scythes
ukiyora is the fourth espada in eisens
ranks his tattoo location is on the left
side of his chest and his aspect of
death is nilism ukiyora isn't just an
incredibly strong asparta but also one
that possesses a very keen intellect he
is gifted at understanding the situation
at hand and has great insight his calm
collected nature combined with his
intelligence is something that eisen who
has a masterful intellect himself has a
lot of respect for
ukiyora also has solita vista which is
spanish for a custom view and japanese
for inclusive field of view where he can
replay events that he himself has seen
and also replay those events to others
by removing and crushing one of his eyes
the crushed eye then turns to a dust
that can also relay not only his sight
but his own feelings too
being an asparagus the high speed
regeneration that he has obviously
replenishes these crushed eyes of his
he can also create large television
screens made out of individual gargantua
portals to put together a visual
broadcast of events he is currently
witnessing
ukiyora's zompagto is called murcielago
which is spanish for bat and japanese
for great black winged demon his zompok
toe resembles that of a standard katana
and his resurrects young release command
is in close or in prison
upon release ukiora's appearance becomes
more bat-like as he gains two enormous
black wings that protrude from his back
his hair also grows longer gaining two
horns from the hollow mask atop of his
head the black markings on his face
become more triangular and his
fingernails also lengthen
his legs alexion significantly boosts
his strength spiritual power his speed
and his hero
not only that but it comes with a couple
of abilities with the first being luz de
la luna this is spanish for light of the
moon
this ability allows ukiyora to generate
green energy javelins that he will use
to either throw at his opponent at high
speeds or to use as a melee weapon
he also has the cello escodas ability
that all a sparta class have except his
is a black beam with a green outline
packing one hell of a punch now ukiyora
has a second stage of his resurrection
called segunda as tapa this is spanish
for resurrection second stage and
japanese for second stage resurrection
ukiyora calls his second state true
despair and states that he is the only
oronkar in the espada who can perform a
second stage of azalaxian and even eisen
himself hasn't seen this form
now appearance wise this form looks
amazing as he keeps his black bat wings
his coat from the previous form is no
more bearing his bare chest with his
hollow hole becoming larger and has like
a black blood liquid coming from it he
has black fur covering the waist down as
well as his arms he also gains claw
extensions from his fingers and his
irises turn yellow the hollow mask is
now completely gone as well as his
espada tattoo
so his spiritual power is again
dramatically increased so much so that
those that can feel his spirit power
feel complete despair themselves
he has an ability called latigo which is
spanish for whip where ukiora will use
his long thin tail like a whip to either
strike lift or even strangle his
opponent
the big boy ability in his second stage
is called lanzar del relampargo which is
spanish for lance of lightning and
japanese or lance of thunder and
lightning
using his insane spiritual power ukiora
creates a javelin similar to the ones in
his previous form however these have
spirit energy flowing off of either side
that look like green flames making it
more arrow-shaped
again he can use this for both range and
melee attacks but when used at range the
destructive power of this thing is just
absolutely nuts
ukiora can throw three of these in quick
succession though in doing so he has
difficulty in controlling their accuracy
these things also tend to instantly
disintegrate anything that they strike
halibel is the third ranked espada in
eisen's army her tattoo location is on
her right breast and her aspect of death
is sacrifice
halabel is incredibly gifted with the
sword but one of the things that makes
her unique is the fact that she is
ambidextrous meaning that she can easily
swap her sword between her left and
right hand while wielding the same
prowess with both
her zompog toe is called taboran which
is spanish for shark and japanese for
supernal shark empress herzompokto is
unique in appearance as it isn't very
long but it is wide and it is also
completely hollow in the middle she has
an ability called ola azol spanish for
blue wave and japanese for blue wave gun
halibell pulls her sword backwards as it
charges itself with yellow spirit energy
in that hollow portion of the blade once
charged she can fire the energy as a
blast straight at her opponent she can
also keep that energy stable within the
blade and use it as a sort of ribbon
when attacking
so her reselection command is destroyed
her appearance changes to that of a much
more revealing one as both her clothes
and her espada tattoo are gone her mask
becomes the only garment that is now
covering her on her arms she gains
gauntlets that are like shark fins and
have two ribbons that protrude from her
back she also gains a spine-like pattern
on her stomach and wears a mini skirt
made out of bones
her sword also changes to resemble that
of a giant shark tooth that has a pretty
unusual hilt as well as a handguard that
completely covers her hand
in terms of power in her resurrection
form her physical powers are all
enhanced and she also gains abilities
that are all water-based
the main ability she has is that she can
create and manipulate water the water
that is used for her attacks are all
generated from the gill in her sword and
she had an ability called trident where
she will infuse her sword with spirit
energy causing it to glow she will then
fire three high-speed slashes that will
cause severe injury upon impact
then there is herviendo which is spanish
for boiling and japanese for burning
current
halibul will simply point her blade out
in front of her and any water that is
near her will instantly boil including
that of ice
lagota which is spanish for drop and
japanese for war drop is an ability
where halibel will condense a large
amount of water around her sword that
she will fire towards her target the
blast of water is in the shape of a
shark's tooth and she can fire multiple
blasts in very quick succession
the final ability is called cascada
which is spanish for waterfall and
japanese for cutting waterfall this one
is simple enough as it is a large blast
of rushing water fired straight towards
her enemy
neliel was the former third espada also
known as nell two
her tattoo location is on her mid-back
and her aspect of death is unknown
so first let's talk about her child form
where she has a couple of abilities the
first is called nel shower where her
saliva possesses a very weak healing
power so to gain this saliva nell will
make herself vomit and then use the
saliva on the poor soul who needs
healing
she also has chokasaku this is super
acceleration that does look like it's a
form of scenido
now nellie l's special ability is called
cello double which is spanish for double
zero and japanese for heavy duet hollow
flash
this is an ability where she will absorb
an incoming seto and then fire one of
her own shadows while returning the one
she had absorbed she can still do this
in her child form but in her true form
this is much more devastating
so in her true form neliel zompoc toe is
called gamuza which is japanese for
capricorn knight
her residency on command is declare or
praise nellie elle's new form is like
that of a centaur where her lower half
is like that of a horse her hollow mask
becomes longer and curved and the crack
that was once on her mask is now
completely gone though the missing teeth
still remain on her shoulders are now
white spolders that cover the shoulder
blade and her neck as well as this she
also has white elbow guards and white
gauntlets her sword is also replaced
with a giant double-sided
lance now the only attack we have seen
neliel use in her resurrection form is
called lanzador verde which is spanish
for green lancer and japanese for
kingfisher green javelin
here neliel throws her javelin at her
opponent with intense speeds as the
javelin travels through the air it
begins to spin and build up spiritual
energy that will drill her opponent upon
impact the destructive piercing damage
of this attack is brutal
brutal enough that it damaged noy torres
zompoc toe and pushed him back when he
attempted to block it
baragon is the second rank to spada and
was the former ruler of los noches known
as the god king of waco mundo his tattoo
location is unknown and his aspect of
death is senescence
as the representation of this aspect of
death aka aging brought on by time he
has some abilities linked to this
so the first is a time dilation field
that will slow the acceleration of time
around him meaning that those trying to
attack him are all reduced in their
normal speeds
this gives barragan more than enough
time to counter-strike those in his area
he also has age acceleration where he
can accelerate the age of anything that
he touches he used this on soy phone
ageing her left arm to the point that
the bones broke due to how delicate they
had become
his zampato is called arogante which is
spanish for arrogant and japanese for
grand emperor of skulls his zampogto is
unique just as noytora's as his takes
the form of a giant double-headed
battleaxe rather than that of a normal
sword the release commander of israel
axion is rot or decay unlike the other
espada barragan undergoes a visual
transformation
so purple flames appear that begin to
burn his own flesh until all that
remains are bones he has a skeletal head
and arms and his body is covered in a
purple cape with a black fur collar
he wears golden chains around his neck
that at the center has a red gem which
was the eye of his zompot toe
his hollow mask has turned into an
elegant and beautifully designed golden
crown that is worn upon his head or
skull i guess you could say here
like many others his resurrection has
greatly enhanced all of his previous
physical abilities and has also enhanced
his synacia his mere presence ages and
deteriorates every object that is around
him meaning he is pretty much invincible
when it comes to close range attacks
even most range attacks have no effect
as when the projectiles enter his space
they are aged and decay at an alarming
rate
he also has the ability respira which is
spanish for breathe and japanese for
breath of death barragan unleashes a
black and purple mist from himself that
ages and rots anything that it comes
into contact with
barragan can also control the speed at
which this mist is unleashed as well
the final ability barrigan has in his
resurrection form is called gran kaida
which is spanish for great fall and
japanese for acts of ruin barragan can
wield a double-sided axe like his zampok
toe but in a resurrection form that is
hidden inside of his purple cloak the
axe is slimmer in this form and the
blades look like wings it has also got
golden chains that drape over the blades
and extend back into his cloak that are
attached to a bracelet that he is
wearing
this axe boasts incredible power and can
be used to spread his respira mist by
swinging it
stark is the first ranked espada in
eisen's army his tattoo location is on
the back of his left hand and his aspect
of death is solitude
the main thing to point out about stark
is how highly perceptive he is while in
combat he picks up on all of the tiny
details during a battle such as his
opponent's mannerisms which he then
breaks down into the reasoning behind
their attack patterns as well as that
person's strengths and weaknesses
he can also work out a person's attacks
by simply observing them once
now stark is definitely unique when it
comes to the espada as his power is not
sealed within a zompark toe but is
instead sealed within his own
subordinate lily net with whom the two
of them were once the same hollow
this second being if you will is called
los lobos which is spanish for the
wolves and japanese for just simply
wolves the release command for his
resurrection is kickabout or give chase
in his released form stark wields two
identical pistols
these pistols are actually lily net as
the pistols contain her body and her
consciousness
she herself can talk through these
pistols and can still feel things too
a part of lilianette's hollow mask now
appears on stark's head that stretches
from the back all the way around to his
eyepiece on his left eye the mask is
connected by two chains again around
that left eye attire-wise he also gains
the addition of a grey fur lined jacket
over a double-breasted vest and his legs
are covered in dark skin-tight pants
while his lower legs and arms are
covered in that same great fur
the ability of his resurrection followed
trend where they greatly enhance his
previous stats but also grant him new
abilities
so he has enhanced strength and enhanced
yellow but he also has enhanced shadow
firing as he can fire these from his
twin pistols without needing to charge
them
stark himself claims that he can shoot 1
000 saddle at once
according to shoon sui the seto shot
from the right gun are more powerful but
the cerro fired from the left pistol are
much faster
he also has the ability cerro matrella
which is spanish for submachine gun zero
and japanese for infinite ammunition
hollow flash this is where stark will
use his pistols to unleash a powerful
barrage of sedo that will fuse together
to make one giant and very powerful
shadow blast if that wasn't enough stock
can also change the direction of the
shadow while firing making it near
impossible to avoid
stock also has colmillo which is spanish
for fang here stark can summon swords
made of spiritual energy that look like
regular katana
the final ability is soul partition
which is an ability that comes from
their original hollow where they can
split and divide their two souls however
when they are combined they can split
themselves into other entities such as a
large pack of wolves at the cost of
their pistols
stark commands the pack of wolves to
track down his enemies and once found
the wolves will bite their target and
explode upon impact these wolves can
move through cracks and extend their
bodies so they can unleash a fast and
accurate attack
stark has said that these wolves are way
more deadlier than asedo and can
overwhelm two captain-classed opponents
at the same time
yami is the 10th ranked sparta however
comes rank zero once his zompoc toe is
unleashed his tattoo location is on his
left shoulder and his aspect of death
is rage
his power comes from his aspect of death
which is rage and he is the only espada
who can conserve his own spirit energy
by sleeping and eating these power
reserves build up over time allowing him
to enter his resurrection form which
unleashed his true power and changes his
espada rank completely
as yami's anger increases as does his
physical size and power too
now he has an ability called gonzwi
which is unique to him yami can suck out
the souls from the living which to him
he sees is just another form of eating
obviously the more souls he eats the
more spiritual energy he can add to his
reserves
and interestingly he has stated that the
weaker the soul's spirit energy the
worst it tastes to him
so his zombocto that is called ira which
is spanish for anger and japanese for
enraged beast his resurrection command
is enraged to which his zampokto
explodes and yami grows into an insane
size that looks like a japanese kaiju
his skull ridges become more pronounced
and become head coverings going around
the back of his head and the white
hollow mask fragments become his jaw his
entire body becomes a more tanned colour
and his ponytail also increases in
length his upper body remains roughly
about the same only larger however he
gains eight huge white elephant legs and
had a white tail that is shaped like a
club he also has large tubes that come
out of his elbows and he gains five
black tubes similar to the ones on his
elbows but these appear on his back
now in terms of abilities when in this
form well it's basically just one huge
power up his strength spiritual power
and endurance all skyrocket the defenses
of his hero are dramatically increased
and his sero and bala blasts are also
greatly enhanced
now the crazy thing is that it doesn't
stop there as he also has rage powered
evolution where both his size and
strength still continue to grow the more
he becomes angrier there is actually a
certain level of anger that he can reach
that will cause his resalexion to evolve
further where his appearance changes
his damage mask is now restored the
black tubes on his back become more like
a spiked spine and he gains two
absolutely massive horns that protrude
from his back
he also gains numerous horns on his head
some that cover his jaw
he takes on the form of more of a
gorilla here where his arms are puffed
outwards and he has two hairy legs with
toes instead of the eight elephant legs
that he had in his pre-evolved form
this guy is just absolutely insane when
it comes to power and man i'm sure none
of us saw this coming when we were first
introduced to him as the 10th ranked as
spada
and that is it every asparta's power and
ability from bleach explained these guys
are just nuts when it comes to their
powers but also in their designs i
always thought the espada just looked so
unique and not only in their resalexion
forms though of course that is where the
true beauty of their designs come to
life
definitely make sure to let us know in
the comment section below who your
favorite asparta is and which one you
thought looked the best design wise
of course if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more bleach videos on
the channel make sure to let us know by
smashing that like button get sugar
tensho style
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime or broad videos
remember you can also follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
thanks again and we cannot wait to see
you in the next one
peace